culture maintenant avec notre invité
andrzej zulawski bonsoir votre dernier
film la note bleue sort en salles
mercredi la note bleue c'est celle de
chopin ou vous avez décidé de raconter
les dernières heures de sa relation avec
georges semble qu'elle qui vous a attiré
dans ces deux personnages surtout la
musique de frédéric chopin qui est une
des plus belles au monde et qui soit et
puis une constatation c'est que chopin
au contraire de beaucoup d'autres
compositeurs musiciens comme mozart par
exemple n'a pas eu de biographie très
agitée il lui est arrivé qu'une seule
chose dans sa vie je crois vraiment
nageurs c'est à dire qu'il a rencontré
vécu pendant neuf ans pratiquement avec
george sand qui était un peu le
contraire de ce qu'il était lui et je
raconte j'essaye de raconter la journée
où tous tous ceux qui se lèvent le matin
c'est très beau et c'est l'été c'est nos
rangs la maison de george sand milieu de
la france ils ne savent pas qu'ils vont
se quitter
vous savez ce sont ces moments de
bonheur qui qui finit son malheur sans
qu'on se passe que il ya eu accumulation
parce que au bout de neuf ans il a
toutes les raisons pour se quitter
eh bien ça raconte ça et ça raconte
aussi sa compta seulement le moment de
se quitter ça raconte un moment d'amour
entre chopin et la fille de george sand
essayer de prendre la place de la mer
pour dix mille raisons est qu'il n'a pas
tout à fait réussi alors vous parliez
tout à l'heure de l'importance de la
musique et vous avez fait un pari un peu
fou c'est de faire jouer le rôle de
frédéric chopin
non pas un acteur mais un pianiste
c'était un peu la condition de le faire
vous savez quelqu'un qui passe dix
heures par jour au piano dans sa vie ce
qui est le cas de chopin dans le film
qui embête tout le monde avec sa musique
du matin au soir qui rabote qui essaye
de faire au mieux j'imaginais mal un
acteur vous savez donc qu'on pourrait
prendre en gros de planton
le meilleur jeu possible et puis les
mains d'un autre et je pensais que la
moindre des choses serait de prendre un
chemin chopin c'est à dire en chef un
vrai manque et nice on va regarder tout
de suite un extrait de votre film d'un
autre bleu
le
très fatigué tu peux t'appuyer sur moi
plus fermement tu sais
vous l'avez dit cette histoire c'est un
petit peu un imprimé déteste les
extraits je vous dis franchement vous
allez partir ralenti le film dure deux
heures dix donc on a le temps de
s'installer dans ces négociations
vous disiez c'est un petit peu un trio
de destructeur qui a entre marie france
pisier qui joue george-sand frédéric
chopin et sophie marceau qui joue la
fleet de marivan de jorge sans non je
pense pas destructeur je pense que
chopin qui avait 39 ans à l'époque et
qui est mort trois ans plus tard à
l'issue d'ailleurs de cette rupture donc
ça lui a coûté très cher était quelqu'un
de malade de très délicat et en même
temps de dos au sommet de ces forces
créatrices et son histoire d'amour et je
le dis avec beaucoup de prudence parce
que nous n'avons pas toutes les preuves
de sa nounou nous en avons les traces
sont en tout cas très forte
son histoire d'amour avec cette très
jeune fille qui lui offrait un regain de
vie un avenir un espoir pour quelques
temps je pense a été très importante
pour lui donc c'est pas tellement de la
destruction c'est plutôt george sand qui
avait trait à ces mots je peux à ce
moment là bas ils veulent ainsi je vous
remercie et donc aller voir le film
puisque les extraits centre court